the white house doing some serious
damage control after hhs secretary
javier becerra defended president
biden's plan to push
back scenes by going door to door
the federal government has had it spent
trillions of dollars to try to keep
americans alive during this pandemic so
it is
absolutely the govern government's
business it is taxpayers business
if we have to continue to spend money to
try to keep people from contracting
covet
and helping reopen the economy
becerra is now trying to walk back that
comment claiming he was taken
wildly out of context jesse yeah that's
a way to convince people to get
vaccinated is the government's going to
show up at your front door
well luckily no one saw that because it
was on cnn ah
and i have an idea i don't have good
ideas often but this is actually a very
innovative idea tell me if this works
if you're worried about people that
aren't vaccinated why don't you create
an app
you push a button and then you have a
doctor come to your house and jab you
i mean they have history of building
websites joe biden knows how to build a
website remember
he should be able to do this why do they
have to go door-to-door
they don't have to go door-to-door if
someone comes on my property
not always a good result and i'm a
lightweight think about the people in
texas
i would not want to have that duty to
put on a uniform
and have a syringe and go knocking on
rando's doors that is a recipe for
disaster
and biden doesn't even know the hhs
secretary's name you see forgot it
at the podium today and i just think
this is again
the government trying to go where it
doesn't belong and you don't even need
to get 100 vaccination
you just need to kill the virus and
right now the virus is almost dead
more people are getting shot dead over
the weekend on july 4th that are
dying from coming people are to your
point people are going door to door and
shooting people
seriously remember biden i used to have
that little card here used to keep it
with the body count
of coven 19. he needs a new card yeah he
does treat violence
maybe he could reference that next time
dana if you include people who have
who have natural immunity from clovid
it's
more than 8 out of 10 americans are have
immunity it's about eighty eighty-five
percent
right why why the panic well one of the
things i would say to javier becerra
is that you're not in california anymore
there's a different situation
now and you have to choose your words
carefully like who in the world
looked at all the coverage about vaccine
hesitancy and vaccine passports and
concluded
the best thing we could do today is
announce that we're going to go
door-to-door with vaccines
but they also didn't clarify it right so
the left is saying that the
conservatives are blowing this up and
exaggerating it
but yet at the same time the media can't
just can't explain what the
administration really means by that
is it going door-to-door with uh
information like a leaflet right
well okay well maybe that's fine but is
it going to door with i don't think it's
going to door door-to-door we don't know
i know new jersey's going to we're not
and you have to
choose your words with caution and
sensitivity
if you were going to deal with this
issue and get people vaccinated or get
them the information that they need so
that they can make their own decision
because
jessica it isn't political if you look
at the various groups of people who are
hesitant about getting vaccinated and
this is a white house that has
the has no soft cell none
and that's what it takes well i agree
with dana yesterday when i talked about
this topic for the first time
i was looking it up fiercely to be like
okay are we getting more information
because i think that's a good thing like
when people go
you know grassroots campaigning and you
know vote for so and so here's a leaflet
i didn't think that they were showing up
to actually jab people but i wanted to
know also if they were going to be
tracking names in all of this because we
do know for instance that the government
tracks
um broad numbers about people who have
hiv aids let's say but they don't have
the specific names of that
um obviously there's a rich history of
terrorizing people in this country who
had aids going back to the 80s
so more information more specificity on
that
but it is a little bit of a political
problem when you look at the states so
18 or 19 states
reached that 70 goal by july 4th they
were all blue states
where you when you look at where the
delta variant is really having its
heyday
it's in red states and 99.5
of people who are passing away from
coven 19 right now are people who are
unvaccinated we still do have
more work to do i i can't say like oh
it's no big deal
street violence is a big deal but covet
is still it's a thing
greg go well i mean this is the problem
is that
uh with this new variant
this could never end technically it
could go on forever uh
viruses every new every year now
uh we're primed to see any outbreak as
covid to covet three the reckoning and
the government and the media
will exploit it because they can't help
themselves because if they see any
any inroad for power or control they're
going to use it so they're
this is an amazing has amazing
potential for controlling the population
and that's what worries me i think you
know
the democratic we have two parties
democrats are always
for the solution of big government and
intruding into your life
and republicans have always been about
the individual about you know
we're rugged individuals thank you very
much stay off my porch
we can actually work together with this
but i honestly don't understand this
it's like if you're just showing up with
the leaflets go now you're wasting
people's time
but if you actually said you know what
we're going to be driving around your
neighborhood
and we're going to knock on your door
we're going to have you know a
a a vaccine van i had one of those
yeah but that's fine but i think that
you know my concern is that this thing
could keep going
and they could keep creating problems
potential problems that never really
materialize
and that'll keep us scared and
enthralled you've already seen it los
angeles county you've been vaccinated
wear a mask
absurd yeah hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else